foreign
as a business analyst you have come to
the right place in today's fast-paced
business world having the right
credential to stand out from the
competition is important that's why we
are going to discuss the best business
analyst certifications that can help you
achieve your professional goals business
analysts pay a critical role in the
success of any organization their health
businesses identify problems find
solution and make data-driven decisions
but in so many different certifications
available it can be hard to know where
to start that's why we have compiled a
list of press certifications to help you
become more efficient and effective
business analyst so let's begin with the
first and probably the most regarded
certification in the business analyst
domain post graduate program in business
analysis but before that let me discuss
the agenda for this video we will be
covering the postgraduate program in the
business analysis after that we will see
business analytics by a boot camp moving
ahead we'll see business analyst
certification
after that we'll see business analytics
for strategic decision making
and in last there is postgraduate
program in business Analytics so the
postgraduate program in business
analysis by simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to equip
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as business analysts
this program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
enhance their business analytics skills
and Advance their career in the field so
this program covers various topics such
as business analysts Essentials project
management data analysis data modeling
and data visualization it also includes
Hands-On training in popular business
analyst tools such as you will see here
such as Microsoft Excel jira power bi
and many others upon completing the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
as a business analyst they will also
have access to Simply learns Career
Services which provides guidance and
support to help Learners transition into
the job market
overall the postgraduate program in
business analysts by simply learn is an
excellent option for individuals who
wants to enhance their business analysis
skills and Advance their career
perspective in this field so now next we
have business analytics boot camp by
simply learn this is an intensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business Analytics the program is
delivered online and is intended for
individuals who want to understand
business analysis comprehensively and
how it can be applied to real world
business problems this program covers
various topics such as data analysis
data modeling data visualization and
predictive modeling it also includes
Hands-On training in popular analysis
tools such as R python Excel and W the
business analytics bootcamp is designed
to provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in meaningful way it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insights and
recommendations to stack holder
effectively upon completion of the
program Learners will receive a
certification from Simply learn and the
skills and knowledge required to succeed
in the business analyst role access to
Simply learns Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
now let's see more about the business
analyst master's program this Masters
program I simply learn is a
comprehensive program designed to
provide Learners with a deep
understanding of or business analysis
the program is delivered online and is
intended for individuals who want to
advance their career prospectus in the
field of business analysis the program
covers various topics such as business
analysis Essentials project management
data analysis data modeling and data
visualization it also includes Hands-On
training in the popular business
analysis tools such as Microsoft Excel
Microsoft power VI I and python numpy
signed by the business analyst master
program is designed to provide Learners
with the skills and knowledge required
to succeed as a business analyst it also
focuses on developing the necessary
skills to effectively communicate with
stakeholder manage projects and analyze
data upon completing the program
Learners will also get the certification
and the skills and knowledge required to
succeed in the business analysis role
which provides guidance and support to
help Learners transition into the job
market
the link will be in the description box
for all the courses next we have simply
learns business analytics for strategic
decision making certification program
which is designed to provide Learners
with a practical understanding of
business analysis and how it can be
applied in the real world business
problems the program is delivered online
as intended for individuals who want to
understand business analysts
comprehensively and Advance their career
this program is delivered by Indian
Institute of Technology roorkee this
program covers various topics such as
strategic analysis data modeling data
visualization predictive modeling and it
also includes Hands-On training in
popular analysis tools such as again
Microsoft Excel R and W a business
analysis for static decision making
certification program is designed to
provide Learners with the skills and
knowledge required to analyze and
interpret data create data models and
visualize data in a meaningful way it
also focuses on developing the necessary
skills to communicate insight and
recommendations to stakeholder
effectively upon completing of the
program the learner will get the
certification by IIT roorkee and simply
learn they will also have the access to
Simply lands Career Services which
provides guidance and support to help
Learners transition into the job market
the link will be in the description box
for this course also now we have simply
learned Sports graduate program in
business analytics in a comprehensive
program designed to provide Learners
with a deep understanding of business
analytics the program is delivered
entirely online and is intended for
individuals who want to advance their
career in the field of business
analytics the program covers a range of
topics such as statical analysis data
modeling data visualization machine
learning and Big Data
so this program is sponsored by Purdue
University and you will get the
certification from IBM this program
covers a range of topics such as
tactical analysis data modeling data
visualization machine learning and Big
Data it also includes Hands-On training
in popular analysis tools such as
Microsoft Excel R programming Python and
tableau the postgraduate program in
business analyst is designed to provide
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst or data scientist it focuses on
developing the necessary skills to
effectively communicate insights and
recommendations to stackholders manage
projects and analyze large volume of
data upon completion of the program
Learners will receive a postgraduate
program in data analysis certification
from Simply learn and the skills and
knowledge required to succeed as a
business analytics or data sense rule
they will also have access to Simply
learns Career Services which provides
guidance and support to Learners
transition into the job market overall
these simple learns business analytics
certification is an excellent option for
individuals who wants to gain a deep
understanding of business analysts and
Advance their career in this field this
program is designed to provide Learners
with a comprehensive training in popular
analytics tools and Technologies making
them an excellent choice for individuals
who want to gain practical experience in
this field so with this we have reached
the end of this video make sure to like
share and subscribe to simplygun thank
you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here